das buch das er geschrieben hat gehört
für mich schon allein wegen seines
titels auf die bestenliste ich bin dann
mal weg hat er frech aufs cover
geschrieben und den pilgern hape
kerkeling komiker showmaster
tausendsassa ist ein buch über seine
pilgerreise nach santiago de compostela
verkaufte sich wie nichts obwohl er
darin ganz und gar keine komischen töne
anschlägt über drei millionen verkaufte
exemplare auf der bestsellerliste des
spiegels hat er sich auf platz eins
festgekrallt und demnächst soll es
verfilmt werden
ist das grund genug für ein gespräch in
der sternstunde religion werden sie mich
jetzt vielleicht fragen und ich sage ja
kerkeling hat mit seinem werk ganz
offensichtlich einen nerv der menschen
getroffen
im rhythmus des bürgerbades schildert er
die anstrengungen des weges die
begegnungen mit menschen und stellt die
grundfrage nach sinn und gott dieser
andere nachdenkliche und suchende hape
kerkeling hat uns interessiert
brigitte roth spricht mit ihm über den
mut aufzubrechen und die angst
anzukommen die lehre und das glück
herzlich willkommen hape kerkeling hier
am stern schon tisch wir hatten kaum zu
hoffen gewagt dass sie bald hierher
kommen denn sie haben ja ein sabbatjahr
ausgerufen ist es jetzt mit neujahr zu
ende oder machen sie eine pause von der
pause da ich das was wir jetzt hier
besprechen werden nicht wirklich als
arbeit betrachte ist es noch bestandteil
des sabbat jahr solle das keine arbeit
ist wahr was ist denn bestand des
sabathia dass ich vor allem keine eigene
sendung mache in der zeit also dass ich
nicht mit einer eigenen show auf den
schirm zurückkomme das wird dann
hoffentlich ende diesen jahres der fall
sein
sie sind die einer der wenigen die
solche dinge machen also immer mal
wieder sich zurückziehen sagen ich
brauche keine pause
warum sind für sie pausen so wichtig
weil das was ich betreibe als
entertainer
manchmal durchaus extremist und das new
yorker horst schlämmer es ist eher eine
extreme figur beispielsweise und am ende
ist das dann nicht nur für den
betrachter extrem sondern auch für mich
in der arbeit und insofern gehört es
dazu dass man sich dann wieder
zurückzieht und figuren nicht zu sehr
penetriert und und versucht das letzte
herauszuholen und und immer dem markt zu
gehorchen und insofern ziehe ich mich
dann zurück das ist ein luxus den ich
mir dann wirklich erlauben kann und
insofern auch erlaube ein luxus es gibt
ja aber viele leute die im
scheinwerferlicht stehen sie sich diesen
luxus offensichtlich nicht erlauben und
ich weiß nicht ist es angst dass man
dann vielleicht nicht mehr gefragt ist
wenn man zurückkommt
ich glaube dass das ganz natürlich ist
dass man sich fragt wenn ich einen
schritt zurücktreten und weniger mache
werden die zuschauer sich an mich
erinnern werden sie mich noch sehen
wollen ich glaube dass das eine
natürliche frage ist die sich stellt
aber irgendwann habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen das ganze entspannt zu
nehmen und wenn es denn so wäre das eben
dann keine nachfrage mehr bestünde dann
wäre es nicht schlimm für sie
was würden sie denn noch schreiben das
tun sie ja schon ich habe irgendwo
gelesen sie sind an zwei buchprojekten
was kommt denn eines von den beiden wird
kommen aber welches weiß ich noch nicht
ich bin ich bin mitten in der arbeit
sind gespannt
dieses sabbat ja ist ja exakt eigentlich
sieben jahre nachdem sie zum jakobsweg
aufgebrochen sind ist das bewusst dass
die sieben zahl des sabbats also das ist
irgendwie so ein rhythmus geben
das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen jetzt
wo sie das sagen nein das ist eher
unbewusst passiert aber es war an der
zeit nach zumal ich dinge gemacht habe
die alle sehr erfolgreich sein durften
und normalerweise startet man 34
versuchsballons als entertainer dann kam
noch die veröffentlichung des buches
hinzu aber wenn dann alles auf einmal
nicht nur gut sondern sehr gut
funktioniert dann ist das auch durchaus
mit anstrengung verbunden und
dementsprechend habe ich mir gedacht ich
darf das glück auch nicht zu sehr
herausfordern
und ziehe mich jetzt wieder zurück hier
haben und fragt sich das manchmal das
seminar mit 44 jahren sozusagen alles
erreicht hat was man erreichen kann wie
kann man das noch toppen
ich denke nie darüber nach wie ich dinge
toppen kann sondern arbeitet wirklich
nach dem prinzip das sich eigentlich nur
dinge auf den schirm bringen oder in die
schriftliche form bringe die mich
beschäftigen die mich begeistern die
meine leidenschaft wecken
vielleicht ist auch ein luxus dass man
das sich so leisten kann sehen wer
wirklich so viel glück sie kommen deine
vor seiner der wirklich viel glück hat
gibt es denn auch momente wo sie über
scheitern nachdenken
ja natürlich im rückblick stellt sich
eine karriere oft so dar als sei sie nur
gekrönt gewesen von wunderbaren erfolgen
aber das stimmt natürlich nicht ich
hatte zwischendurch ganz schreckliche
misserfolge und hatte durchaus auch mal
den gedanken mit dem beruf aufhören zu
müssen mangels erfolg ja natürlich das
gehört dazu wie gehen sie damit um wenn
es mal nicht so erfolgreich ist
ich habe sehr früh lernen müssen auch
mit mit misserfolgen umzugehen und
dementsprechend versuche ich wieder den
misserfolg das klingt jetzt sehr
theoretisch aber am ende kann man es in
die praxis umsetzen wiener den
misserfolg zu ernst zu nehmen noch den
erfolg zu ernst zu nehmen das heißt
nicht in lobeshymnen mit zuschlägen und
alles zu glauben was da über einen
geschrieben wird und andererseits wenn
man verrissen wird auch das nicht alles
zu glauben sondern immer zu versuchen
einen gesunden abstand dazu zu halten
ich nehme meinen beruf als entertainer
jetzt auch nicht so ernst während ich
ihn ausüben natürlich schon das ist eine
profession
aber das ist jetzt nichts was die welt
wirklich bewegend was nehmen sie ernst
da soll man denkt ja irgendwo müssen sie
finden das dann so leicht und eben auch
nicht ganz und sicheren lassen zu können
was ich ernst nehme dann beispielsweise
das buch was ich geschrieben habe das
war mir schon das 1 1 ernst
anlegen wie gesagt während ich meinen
beruf ausübe als entertainer nehme ich
die konkrete arbeit sehr ernst
aber der beruf als solches er wird die
welt nicht verändern vielleicht eine
wichtige haltung im grunde genommen hat
dir was ihr körper sie gezwungen also
wenn ich mich zurückerinnern 2001 als
sie aufgebrochen sind zum jakobsbad da
hatten sie gesundheitliche probleme ein
hörsturz gallenoperation zwingt ihr
körper sie fast zum glück offensichtlich
ja ich habe damals einfach wahrzeichen
nicht erkannt und war an einem punkt wo
ich zu viel zu lang zu intensiv
gearbeitet habe und insofern hat der
körper mich zu einer ruhepause gezwungen
zu einem innehalten gezwungen und jetzt
das stimmt das ist jetzt auch wieder so
was war mit rückenproblemen nein aus
schlimmerer drücken ich habe dich gala
war das zu lesen jetzt hätten sie hätten
das jetzt auch nein nein nein
also das ist war jetzt einfach an der
zeit dass ich mich wieder mal
zurücknehmen
aus den eben genannten gründen jetzt ist
es eben das schreiben damals war es der
jakobsbad werden sie auch häufig
gefragte warum eigentlich ausgerechnet
das ist ja doch ein sehr eleganter weg
also diesen weg habe ich damals mehr
oder weniger aus zufall gewählt ich
wollte keinen klassischen urlaub machen
keine klassische rekonvaleszenz sondern
wollte die zeit nutzen um mehr über mich
zu erfahren und am ende vielleicht auch
mehr über über gott zu erfahren das war
schon mein ziel
und da gibt es nun mal drei wege für die
christen da gibt es den weg nach
jerusalem der wäre mir eindeutig zu
beschwerlich gewesen und doch zu
gefährlich
der weg nach rom wäre zu katholisch
gewesen und insofern blieb der
eigentliche pilgerweg der weg nach
santiago
also es war wichtig das ist ein
christlicher weg war für sie nein es
hätte durchaus auch ein buddhistischer
weg sein können nur eine umrundung des
keilers hätte ich damals nicht geschafft
und würde ich auch heute nicht schaffen
und insofern schien mir der weg nach
santiago der richtige was denken sie
denn also es sind ja so wie adern die da
nach santiago gehen sie nicht nur ein
ganz viele durch europa die dahin führen
wenn ich jetzt haben die sie im
nachhinein es ist ein heiliger weg oder
ist es mehr so dass man interessante
leute dort trifft oder das ist gut
ausgeschildert ist
ob es ein heiliger weg ist in gewisser
weise ja also zunächst mal gibt es eine
über ein jahrtausend währende tradition
seit dieser zeit gehen menschen diesen
weg und das besondere an dem pilgerweg
ist dass man eben nicht wandert sondern
pilgert und mitpilger trifft die auf
einer ähnlichen suche sind das macht das
ganze am ende so besonders wenn sie
einen normalen weg werden dann in der
schweiz im schwarzwald wo auch immer
dann treffen sie wanderer aber eben
keine pilger die sich mit den
essentiellen fragen des daseins unter
umständen beschäftigen wir wissen es
nicht und das jetzt der unterschied ist
dass die allermeisten menschen denen man
auf dem weg begegnet bereit sind sich
ohne großen anlauf sofort auf die
essentiellen fragen unseres daseins
einzulassen
das passiert einem schwarzwald behaupte
ich mal jetzt nicht so
und insofern das zeichnet den pilgerweg
aus und es gibt ein klares ziel und
dieses ziel ist eben santiago das grab
des heiligen jakobs man vermutet dass er
dort begraben ist bewiesen ist das ja
nicht warum ist es so wichtig
also es gibt ja auch leute zum beispiel
durch die schweiz ein stück des pfades
pilgern oder durch frankreich das ist
egal am ende steht ja das ziel santiago
ich glaube das ziel steht
stellvertretend für einen fokus für
etwas das man vor augen hat 1 1 das kann
auch ein ziel im übertragenen sinne
seien etwas was man erreichen will und
einen weg zu gehen ohne ein ziel ist
problematisch dann macht der weg als
solcher schon keinen sinn
denken sie ich denke ja also wenn ich
spazieren gehe dann habe ich vielleicht
als ziel wieder mein eigenes zuhause
es ist wiederum ein ziel aber komplett
ziellos durch die gegend zu hören es
glaub ich im spirituellen sinne wenig
ertrag
wer wenig einträglich komme ich aber
schon auf den buddhismus sie benennen
sich ja sagen manchmal sie seien
buddhist mit christlichem überbau im
buddhismus würde man doch eben gerade
nicht auf ein ziel zu gehen oder ja oder
sagen wir mal besser das ziel aus den
augen verlieren während des gehens ich
finde es finde und fand es wichtig ein
ziel zu haben
ich habe großen respekt vor beiden
religionen und insofern ich würde mich
jetzt weder als rein ich würde mich eher
als christ sehen aber durchaus durch den
buddhismus beeinflusst vielleicht kommen
wir auf den buddhismus nochmal zurück
sie haben den jakobus erwähnt und dass
das gab also man sie eine legende
eigentlich dass er dass seine gebeine
dort hingebracht wurden im ersten
jahrhundert ist sehr interessant dass
das eigentlich fast vergessen war und
erst im neunten jahrhundert wieder
wiederentdeckt wurde dieses grab und
auch dieser pilgerweg entstand dass das
so stark oder dass die pilger nach
santiago strömten hatte ja auch ein
bisschen war eine parallele zurück und
christa die damals stadt fahren also
sozusagen das christentum übernimmt
jetzt wieder die vorherrschaft gegen
islam judentum wie sehr war ihnen das
bewusst das ist ja eigentlich auch
fassen kriegsparteien
religionspolitische auf jeden fall sehr
aufgeladen
das ist mir auf dem weg bewusst geworden
wie war das vorher nicht so bewusst
man darf auch nicht vergessen dass
dieser weg auch dazu diente bestimmten
städten in spanien und frankreich geld
zu bringen
so wurde dieser fahrt auch umgelegt
damit also bestimmte städte zölle
erheben konnten es gab einen lebendigen
lebhaften handel mit reliquien also es
gibt auch ganz schön schwierig bis heute
nicht ganz so dramatisch mehr
aber natürlich ist das auch mit mit
geschäft und macht verbunden sonst hätte
dieser weg gar nicht weiter bestehen
können
deswegen darf man es jetzt auch nicht zu
sehr idealisiert
also die entstehung dieses weges hat
auch ganz unangenehmen seiten aber eben
gerade die also dass eigentlich die in
dieser maurischen zeit das zusammen der
religion eigentlich sehr friedlich war
vorbildlich und das war jetzt beim
vorbereiten der sendung erst aufgegangen
wie wie sehr das doch auch mit seinem
hegemonie anspruch des christentums und
natürlich ja
deswegen war es mir so wichtig in meinem
buch deutlich zu machen dass ich diesen
weg nicht in einer klassisch dogma
tischen katholischen tradition pilgere
sondern dass dieser weg heute durchaus
auch eine andere funktion haben kann und
er ist ja nun mal weltkulturerbe und es
gibt viele menschen die diesen weg
laufen nicht unbedingt aus
glaubensgründen sondern menschen die auf
der suche nach sich sind oder einen
neuen weg für sich im leben finden
wollen also fast so eine
psychotherapeutische funktion hat danach
steht kein ausgetreten ein bisschen in
alle die fasten spiritualized werden
richtungen aus vor angst schauen sie der
weg bleibt am ende sehr konkret und egal
mit welcher intention man nun auf diesen
weg geht der weg wird am ende vielleicht
wird das würde dass jeder weg tun aber
ich glaube daran dass dieser weg das im
speziellen tut wird einen prägen
ich glaube das schon und insofern sind
die ganz diffusen dinge nicht möglich
glaube ich das ist eine glaubt ja ich
kann sie nicht beweisen es gibt darüber
keine studien das ist nur ein eindruck
sie denn geprägt wie er mich gedrängt
hat ich glaube dass ich mir eher dinge
verzeihen kann und meinen mitmenschen
auch er dinge verzeihen kann dass ich
verständnisvoller geworden will und das
führe ich auf diese 630 kilometer zurück
die ich da zu fuß zurückgelegt habe nun
ist es möglich dass das auch bestandteil
meiner persönlichen entwicklung ist aber
wenn sie mich nun zwingen würden zu
sagen woher rührt das dann würde ich
sagen ich glaube
ganz wesentlich durch den pilgerweg
geprägt warum also wieso hat also sehr
gut entwickeln aber warum hat die sind
dieser weg sie dazu gebracht
also auf diesem weg ich bin den weg
alleine gelaufen und läuft 630 kilometer
alleine und da geht es vor allem darum
dass ich mit mir zurecht komme dass ich
mich meinen fehlern stelle die nicht
automatisch begegnen mit mir selbst ist
auszuhalten
und das war schon manchmal eine echte
herausforderung und daneben auch zu
sagen gut dass sind teile anteile in mir
die ich jetzt nicht so gerne mehr
anschauen das sind die schatten anteile
die dunklen anteile
die werde ich integrieren müssen ich
kann sie nicht gänzlich ignorieren und
insofern hat dieser weg etwas
[Musik]
integratives also bestimmte bestandteile
der persönlichkeit wirklich zu
integrieren und sich bewusst zu machen
so was zumindest bei mir und
dementsprechend beobachtet man das bei
seinen mitmenschen und stellt auch da
fest dass man eher bereit ist dinge zu
verzeihen also ich war dann eher bereit
menschen dinge zu verzeihen die ich
vorher unverzeihlich fand oder wo ich
dachte man müsse eine harte haltung
haben
warum es ist nun mal so die menschen
sind so jeder mensch macht fehler und
die muss man eben auch verzeihen können
hätte man früher nach ihrer meinung hart
sein müssen
naja wenn es um bestimmte
ungerechtigkeiten geht wenn es um die
wenn es um politische positionen geht
dass man sagt nein das ist jetzt meine
position darauf beharre ich sondern das
dass man eben versucht auf den anderen
sanft einzuwirken und eben auch immer
erkennen muss dass man seine eigenen
fehler hat und nicht ohne tadel ist und
ohne viel
jetzt kommen wir auf das buch im buch
ist ja eine person diese schnabel
vorkommt die frau die sie eigentlich
sehr aufregt um von der sie plötzlich
dann ist mein schatten das war nicht
eigentlich sehr starke passage also ich
denke das ist dass das ist genau das ja
also auch im anderen die eigenen fehler
gespiegelt zu sehen
die eigene eitelkeit eigene
unzulänglichkeiten die eigene ungeduld
und so was sie haben das buch
geschrieben nachdem pfad aber erst fünf
jahre später da fragt man sich ja auch
warum erst nach fünf jahren oder lang
haben sie überhaupt ein buch über diese
so persönliche erfahrung gemacht also
das tagebuch habe ich in der tat während
der pilgerreise geführt weil in meinem
reiseführer der ratschlag stand es
könnte ihnen langweilig werden und sie
könnten aber auch das bedürfnis haben
ihre erlebnisse einfach auf zu schreiben
wenn sie alleine wandern
das habe ich getan und fand ich in der
tat während des weges sehr hilfreich ich
hatte nicht vor es zu veröffentlichen
hatte aber zwischendurch das gefühl dass
es irgendwie veröffentlicht werden will
was ich da geschrieben hat ja das was
ich da geschrieben hatte und und hab es
dann mehr oder weniger dem zufall
überlassen ob es zu einer
veröffentlichung kommt ich habe dann
vier jahre nach dem weg in einer
talkshow in einer ähnlichen situation
wie hier zum ersten mal sehr knapp
darüber gesprochen dass ich diesen weg
gelaufen bin
daraufhin hat sich der piper-verlag bei
mir gemeldet und meinte dass ich darüber
ein kleines büchlein schreiben könnte
und dann habe ich denen eben meine
tagebuchseiten überlassen hat gesagt
schaut euch an ob daraus ein buch werden
kann
aber das buch haben sie selber
geschrieben
zum beispiel dass mit der erkenntnis
dass tag ist das eine eher jeden tages
ende kommt zu einer erkenntnis in dem
buch war das von anfang an schon unter
ex trainer ich habe während ich den weg
gelaufen bin hatte ich nicht jeden tag
eine erkenntnis des tages diese
erkenntnis des tages kam er erst als ich
die meine tagebuch version korrigiert
verbessert habe wo landschaft
beschreibung hinzu kommen mussten
personenbeschreibung und da stellte ich
irgendwann fest dass ich eigentlich an
jedem tag irgendeine lektion gelernt
hatte und so fing ich dann an diese
einsichten des tages zu formulieren
zunächst mal
nicht für jeden tag sondern für einzelne
tage bis wir uns irgendwann dazu
entschlossen haben gesagt haben
eigentlich ist das für jeden tag gut das
ist also später ersten zehn kommen also
das buch hat ja unglaublichen erfolg
gehabt
drei millionen leute haben nicht gelesen
ich habe gemerkt normal dass wenn ich
eher skeptisch wenn ein buch wenn alle
ein buch gut finden dann denke ich wenn
ich das auch und habe gemerkt das hat
mich sehr eingenommen nach überlegt was
es ist und ob es vielleicht diese eben
diese ganz ehrlichen und ganz kleinen
beschreibungen auch über sie selber sein
könnten also diese wie sie zum beispiel
als couchpotato beginnen zu laufen wie
das ist mit dem anhalter also am anfang
bus nehmen und dann nicht mehr und so
haben sie eine these was es ist
die leute anspricht also ich habe
versucht mich zu schönen gegen das ganze
wird dann müsste schon riesig es ist ja
es ist nicht geschönt
ich hab's nicht geschönt und ich habe
natürlich nicht alle passagen die ich in
meinem tagebuch geschrieben hatte ins
buch hinein genommen weil es zum teil zu
privat war und da warte ich unter
umständen verzerren oder schön müssen
das wollte ich nicht
also sind jetzt eigentlich nur die
passagen im buch die ich so gemeint habe
und von denen ich mir einbilde dass ich
das ganz ehrlich niedergeschrieben habe
es war ja nicht dazu bestimmt
veröffentlicht zu werden sondern es war
eine kommunikation mit mir genau und
jetzt nachdem das veröffentlicht wurde
ist ja auch noch interessant was mit
dieser kommunikation mit dieser
erfahrung mit ihnen selber eigentlich
passiert ist
seit das jetzt so an die öffentlichkeit
gekommen ist am anfang fand ich das sehr
ungewöhnlich dass menschen war mir nicht
bewusst wie sehr die dann natürlich an
meinem inneren erleben teilhaben würden
ich bin ja auch nicht davon ausgegangen
dass es am ende so viele menschen sein
würden
das habe ich am anfang sehr befremdlich
gefunden ich habe mich mittlerweile
daran gewöhnt
aber woran ich mich wahrscheinlich nie
werde gewöhnen können ist die tatsache
dass es weit über drei millionen mal
ich will gar nicht sagen verkauft wurde
gelesen wurde
das ist etwas was mich nach wie vor
irritiert fast fast schockiert hat oder
ich kann es gar nicht
also ich habe wirklich nicht mit diesem
erfolg gerechnet
und wie ist es eigentlich mit diesen sie
haben lesungen werden fragen gestellt
werden ja auch immer ein bisschen
dieselben fragen gestellt wie gehen sie
mit dem um also sie haben etwas einmal
erlebt vor sieben jahren
es ist natürlich ein sehr prägendes
erlebnis und insofern hat es für mich
nach wie vor auch eine besondere
bedeutung
ich rede nicht ungern darüber ich rede
gerne darüber
auch über die erlebnisse auf dem
jakobsweg aber ich habe bewusst nicht
allzu viele lesungen gemacht im
deutschen sprachraum werden es 15
lesungen gewesen sein in zwei jahren
weil es einfach kein normales buch ist
mit dem ich hausieren gehen kann und
sagen das ist jetzt ein krimi den ich
geschrieben habe sondern es ist meine
geschichte und insofern hatte ich auch
nicht das gefühl ich sollte dafür allzu
viel promotion machen oder aber das ist
das ist nicht im eigentlichen sinne ein
produkt wenn sie sagen sie reden gerne
darüber gibt seien eines der ergebnisse
wird das jeder gerne reden
ach ich rede gerne wollte diesen
gesamten weg über die erlebnisse über
die menschen die ich dort getroffen habe
ich erinnere mich gerne daran zurück wie
einfach ist auf diesem weg war sehr
schnell in ein intensives gespräch
einzusteigen was wir beide im übrigen
jetzt auch hier haben und und weil es
eine vorgabe gibt die heißt sternstunden
und wir dürfen also und dass wir beide
vor übers wetter reden müssen und wie es
uns sonst so geht relativ schnell ans
eingemachte kommen und das film mache
ich es mir eigentlich sehr lieb
unterricht das ersparen weil sagen wir
jetzt dieses gespräch hat ja eben die
vorgaben des ist und solange es findet
hier statt seinen anfang und ein ende
und bei mia popstar das ist ja auch so
ein punkt es gibt diese etappen man weiß
genau ich laufe von da nach
an dem tag neben sie am vortag es gibt
dieses dieses ziel wie wichtig war denn
diese äußere strukturierung jetzt auch
für die erfahrung des wegs also während
man läuft verliert man diese äußere
struktur weil die tagesetappen zum teil
schier unerreichbar scheint und das
eigentliche ziel in so weiter ferne
rückt das man nicht das gefühl hat man
man würde einen strukturierten weg
laufen
zumal sich erst bei mir sehr spät diese
struktur des weges auch in mir wieder
gefunden hat
mir war es eher ungeordnet und chaotisch
und ich habe wenn sie diesen wild laufen
dann im besten fall können sie diese
ordnung des weges für sich übernehmen
als person im übertragenden sinne das
ziel für sich übernehmen
die struktur des weges übernehmen
etappen laufen etappen gehen und das hat
bei mir eine zeit lang gedauert bis sich
diese struktur des weges auch für mich
als sicherheit empfinden konnte und ihr
irgendwann vertrauen konnte und wusste
ich werde am ende diesen weg zu ende
laufen nachdem ich mir den weg so
strukturiert hatte dass er für mich ja
laufbahn wurde an das kann's nicht
familie war das verständlich nein ich
erinnere mich jetzt gerade einfach dass
sie auch mal den tag in einem kloster
war und da ist es ja noch klar oder es
gibt die gebetszeiten des klingelte der
mann hört die glocke man geht man lässt
alles vor allem jahr geht er sofort ist
die ordnung finden das ist noch strenger
als auf dem pfad aber offensichtlich
hatte er doch mit der zeit etwas gemacht
mit ihrer inneren ordnung
der pfad auch ja natürlich weil das
könnte auch ein unterschied sein zu
sagen wir mal sie werden in den amazonas
gefahren und hätten sich irgendwie durch
den urwald ein weg gesucht hier es gab
den pilgerstempel es gab als gab die
verschiedenen dinge die das ganze
geordnet haben ja und das ist natürlich
am ende nie wirklich lebensgefährlich
das darf man nicht vergessen es geht
darum dass man läuft und diese
körperliche anstrengung ist schon nicht
ohne
aber es ist ja nie wirklich
lebensgefährlich und insofern hat man
zeit sich auch über die schmerzen die
man ja jeden tag spürt erfahrung über
über das normale maß hinaus zu sammeln
stich wo das mir jetzt beim lesen auch
immer wieder aufgefallen war die lehre
ich weiß nicht wie das jetzt im
zusammenhang steht eben mit dieser
strukturierung mit der inneren ordnung
oder unordnung es kommt häufig vor es
gibt auch so wenn man eine erkenntnis
des tages mit der lehre der lehrer ja
also das was ich damit gemeint ist die
erkenntnis des tages ist die lehre die
vollends glücklich macht sogar ja das
glaube ich auch dass das so ist also auf
dem weg wird man zwangsläufig irgendwann
leer laufen alle emotionen am loswerden
negative selbst positive emotionen es
geht darum zu laufen das ist das ziel
man will in santiago ankommend
irgendwann hat man sich emotional
leergelaufen und erreicht so eine art
zustand es nicht nicht wollen oder oder
nicht mehr
man will nichts mehr erreichen dennoch
dennoch läuft man auf das ziel zu und
und diese diese lehre also dieses keine
erwartungen haben keine keine wünsche
das gefühl dass es an nichts mangelt das
alles bereits da ist das ist ein gefühl
das man schwer beschreiben kann
aber das ist in der tat ein gefühl
großen glücks also irgendwie fliegt als
falsch großer freude großer freude was
ich da unterschied
ein glück ist etwas etwas momentanes
wobei freude etwas ist was man tief
empfindet und was durchaus auch ein
leben anhalten kann
es ist das was man auch in
grenzerfahrung manchmal findet so etwas
hat es ihr mit der anstrengung auch zu
tun dass man gar nicht mehr die kraft
hat was anderes zu denken ja ja
der körper ist dann so überfordert im
positiven sinne dass er gar nicht mehr
sich mit alltäglichen kleinen
problemchen herumwälzen kann ich das
gelesen habe ich mir meist sinn gekommen
dass in seinen deutschen predigten heißt
es zum beispiel eben da heißt es immer
wieder aber dass man muss leer werden
muss eine lehre das finde ich ja ich
habe es muss ich zu meiner schande
gestehen einige lesen ich kann ihnen die
kopie der heißt es ein gefäß kann
zweierlei trank nicht fassen und eben
dann muss man das zuerst alles aus
gießen
alles was aufnehmen und empfänglich sein
will das soll und muss leer sein
das finde ich also allawis tische es
geht an einrichtungen ist die quasi
frisch nur dass meister eckhart das
deutlich besser vorbereitet als ich aber
darum geht es ja darum geht es ist es
geht auch um und mystic dabei ganz klar
das ist auch etwas durchaus mystisches
würde das auch als mystische erfahrung
bezeichnen wollen ja da kommt man ja
dann ist das war auch im buch kommt
nachher die gottesbegegnung nach dieser
lehre also denken sie kurzes begegnung
muss aus oder kann erst auf seine lehrer
folgen oder ist in dieser leer also ich
würde so etwas nie absolut behaupten
oder sagen wollen ich kann immer nur von
meiner persönlichen erfahrung sprechen
und inwieweit die womöglich übertragbar
ist auf alle oder andere menschen das
wage ich nicht zu beurteilen
aber für mich gilt das und ich würde
diese begegnung also diese lehre wieder
auffüllen lassen
mit etwas anderem als gottesbegegnung
beschreiben wollen ja
sie sagen sie können und wo ihr eigener
erfahrung reden aber häufig sagen sie ja
sie können nicht davon reden das hat so
etwas weil es wirklich das problem ist
in dem moment wo ich versuche es ihnen
zu beschreiben reichen meine worte nicht
mehr aus es ist klingt hohl es klingt
leer es klingt banal
das ist es aber nicht das ist es auch
aber ich kann nur den banalen teil den
profanen teil beschreiben den das was
ich eben beschreibe dass man sich leer
läuft das man aufgefüllt wird das klingt
ja alles sehr banal diesen teil kann ich
beschreiben aber das was für mein
empfinden für meine für mein verständnis
darüber hinaus geht was eben nicht
profan ist sondern vielleicht eine art
heiligkeit hat das entzieht sich meiner
möglichkeit es zu beschreiben ich kann
es nicht beschreiben man das wort das im
grunde sehen einer der ganz leicht mit
sport mit dialogen
das sind etwa so es ist in etwa so also
ich kann es auch nur wieder tatsächlich
beschreiben wie das gefühl ist wenn man
läuft das ist so also also nehmen wir
das studio als beispiel als würde erst
diese wand weggenommen werden dann würde
uns der tisch weggenommen werden dann
die gläser und dann würden wir beide uns
nur noch gegenübersitzen
so in etwa fühlt sich das an aber auch
das ist wiederum das trifft es am ende
auch nicht überhaupt dann geschrieben
weil er seither wird der geräte sind sie
werden eben auch ständig danach gefragt
hat ja nicht wirklich beschreiben können
ich habe es mir dass ich den gott
begegnet ja und ich das habe ich auch
für mich so erlebt aber wie will man
etwas beschreiben was nicht beschreibbar
ist es ist einfach nicht beschreibbar
und war ja das ist ja warum haben sie
dann trotzdem sozusagen das so man
hingesetzt und auch neugierig gemacht
also es ist ja mein tagebuch und
insofern ist bestandteil eines
tagebuches und ich wollte damit wieder
neugierig machen
nur ich hätte es auch als
ja als fehler gesehen wenn ich das einen
potenziellen leser vorenthalten hätten
deswegen war ich ja gelaufen das war ja
der grund warum ich diesen weg gelaufen
bin und dass aus dem buch heraus zu
nehmen das hätte ich als als wirklich
als großen fehler empfunden also habe
ich versucht es soweit es in meinen
möglichkeiten steht es zu beschreiben
und das ist nun mal mangelhaft
ich finde denn eigentlich hoch
interessant also ich gebe ihnen
vollkommen recht dass man das eigentlich
nicht beschreiben kann aber dass es
vielleicht auch ein stück ein modernes
problem ist also das dass wir
individuell unsere erfahrung nach gottes
erfahrungen mit eigenen worten
beschreiben müssen während ich denke
früher hatte man doch viel mehr also man
kann einem sozial man kann man sich in
eine liturgie geht man konnte die alten
traditionellen gornja immer noch und
wenn sie einen psalm lesen dass es
beispielsweise ein wunderschönes
beispiel ich glaube dass das jedem jeder
mensch dann die möglichkeit hat in diese
dimension einzutauchen
am ende geht es um liebe es geht um
glaube ich es geht am ende nur um liebe
dass es das eigentliche wenn es denn ein
geheimnis gibt was was es zu begreifen
gibt dann geht es um liebe also kann es
doch beschreiben ja wenn sie so wollen
ja aber dennoch müsste ich ihnen jetzt
den vorgang beschreiben dann wäre es das
problem hat etwas geht natürlich um
liebe
na das hat jetzt aber gedauert wie sich
aus bekommen die wir auch schneller
haben können schuldige und stand auf der
leitung
aber doch nicht so es ist doch schon
auch die frage nach ob unsere zeit auch
ein hunger hat wieder nach nach formen
wieder nach nach worten die eben auch
vermittelbar sind durch jetzt nicht
sozusagen als beispiel nehmen wir es
vielleicht vielen von uns eben geht
gerade mit diesen mit religiösen sachen
fragen wird also das was ich in dem buch
ja behauptet
ist dass es möglich ist so eine art
persönliche beziehung zu gott zu haben
das ist das was ich in den raum stelle
und ich glaube dass dass es das gibt ich
glaube dass das geht und da steht
natürlich in ihm gewissermaßen auch im
widerspruch zu dem was die offizielle
kirche lehrt na ja es geht um die eltern
steht da steht immer das dogma steht am
serien katholisch ich war katholisch
aber ich bin nach wie vor katholisch ich
glaube bin ich auch wenn man da austritt
bleibt man sie haben ende
das steht dann immer dazwischen und es
geht auch um die vermittlung sie es gibt
immer ein vermittler der zwischen den
gläubigen und dem allerhöchsten steht
und da muss man sehr weit laufen
offenbar nicht
das schreibe ich an dem buch ich
beschreibe meine erfahrung und ich denke
am ende macht jedes individuum seine
eigenen erfahrung und ich würde nie
konstatieren dass es so sein muss und
nur so sein kann
das ist meine erfahrung nicht mehr nicht
weniger jetzt ist natürlich spannend
der pfad ist 70 jahre her dass sie den
gegangen sind sie sind in santiago
angekommen das ist ja auch spannend am
buch das sie angst haben vor dem
ankommen und dann wird beschrieben wie
das dann war das doch eigentlich sehr
festlich war aber das buch hört auf sie
zum bahnhof in vigo gehen ja was ist mit
dieser erkenntnis dann passiert mit der
angst man ja es war es werk mehrere
waren gleichzeitig sie haben jetzt
gesagt sie haben diese persönliche
gottesbeziehung habe ich erfahren und
interessant was sie von dem mitgenommen
haben nach dem pfad
zunächst erstmal nicht allzu viel
man nimmt dann eine richtungsänderung
also so ist es mir gegangen eine eine
richtungsänderung vor und wenn sie ich
mache als beispiel mal also ich war
zunächst so ausgerichtet
nun richtet man sich plötzlich so aus
das bedeutet für die coole spitze nur
eine leichte drehung kaum spürbar
aber in der konsequenz bedeutet dass in
eine komplett andere richtung zu gehen
eben nicht da lang zu laufen sondern da
lang zu laufen also ist es gleichzeitig
eine sehr kleine veränderung aber am
ende grundsätzlich eine fundamentale
veränderung und am anfang fühlte sich
das für mich nicht fundamental dachte
das war's jetzt merke ich aber sieben
jahre danach dass ich wirklich in einer
eine komplett andere richtung gegangen
bin
können sie das beschreiben also ich kann
mir das von den winkeln her jetzt mit
dem kolleg kann ich mir gut vorstellen
was das heißt also konkret profan in
meinem leben bedeutet das dass ihr dass
ich erst mal dieses buch veröffentlicht
habe
den eigentlichen weg den ich bis dahin
bestritten hatte fast nicht aufgegeben
habe aber doch nahezu verlassen habe um
eine komplett andere richtung zu gehen
ja die aber auch ganz anders waren als
das was ich vorher gemacht habe die die
sich auch anders anfühlt aber das
konkret zu formulieren ist ist schwer
ich würde sagen dass ich jemand bin der
besser mit seinen eigenen fehlern und
besser mit den fehlern anderer umgehen
kann
ich glaube dass ich jederzeit bereit
wäre komplett neu zu starten etwas neues
von heute auf morgen anzufangen dass ich
davor keine angst hätte auch das führe
ich auf den weg zurück das sind am ende
sind es banale erkenntnisse aber es sind
doch die erkenntnisse die unser leben
also die mein leben ausmachen
das haben sie auch schon gesagt dass das
die erkenntnis jeder sekunde neu
anzufangen
das finde ich eigentlich nicht banal das
ist ja ziemlich gewaltig also tragen ja
das glaube ich es wird ja früher oder
später wird es jeder mensch erleben und
dann werde ich natürlich gut also keinen
keinem menschen sind tragödien im leben
erspart sei es durch den tod eines
lieben menschen was so die schlimmste
tragödie sein kann wo man dazu
aufgerufen ist komplett neu sein leben
auszurichten
und ich glaube dafür sollte man einfach
immer bereit sein und wenn das jetzt
eigentlich so sind ja sehr positives
dinge die sie damit genommen haben nach
veränderungen an sich
warum eben dann doch diese angst
anzukommen
das war auf dem weg so weil ich die
erwartung hatte
es wird mein leben radikal von jetzt auf
gleich verändern
es wird dafür sorgen dass ich nie wieder
stress empfinden also so eine art super
mein gefühl das war sozialist nein aber
das ist so die das war dann doch schon
die erwartungshaltung am ende wenn ich
ehrlich bin und das drückt natürlich so
nicht ein es dauert dann sehr lange bis
das leben bleibt bis man merkt hartmann
ist doch tatsächlich in eine gänzlich
andere richtung gelaufen als man das
zuvor als alt man ist den weg nicht
weiter gegangen die man vorher
eingeschlagen hatte und die werden das
zurückkommen in die zivilisation ich
könnte mir das auch noch gar nichts
einfach vorstellen wenn man wieder nach
hause kommt und ich hatte einen näheren
bezug zu entfernen
ich bin elf zwölf kilometer mal eben so
gelaufen und fand das auch nicht viel
ich habe meine wäsche 14 tage danach
noch jeden tag mit der hand gewaschen
danach nicht
danach dachte ich auch jetzt ist es aber
du hast eine waschmaschine
aber solche rituale habe ich habe ich
durchaus beibehalten
und ich merke wenn ich heute spazieren
gehe das sich sehr schnell wieder diese
attitüde des weges habe also das stellt
sich automatisch wieder ein
haben sie manchmal sehnsucht den weg
wieder zu gehen sie haben sie glaube ich
kann man versucht was aber nicht
funktioniert hat bin vor zwei jahren
wollte ich von porto nach santiago de
compostela also von vom norden portugals
rauf nach santiago 150 kilometer man
glaube ich der 200 kilometer laufen und
er waren aber waldbrände so dass sich
gezwungen war den weg zu unterbrechen
also bin ich ihnen nicht ein zweites mal
gelaufen und können sie sich vorstellen
es gibt ja auch so bekannt sind sie
angekommen planen sie das nächste stück
das nächste mal nach sagt ich kann die
menschen die da seine sucht werden ja
weil es halt so ein gefühl der
glückseligkeit vermittelt das pilgern im
besten sinne und insofern kann ich
verstehen dass man danach süchtig wird
vielleicht mache ich es irgendwann noch
mal vielleicht auch nicht ich weiß also
ihr buch wird er demnächst verfilmt und
durch die frage werden sie dann sich
selber spielen der auf diesem pfad geht
nein nein also das ist das muss dann ein
schauspieler aber das land darstellen
ich weiß es nicht das ist ein experiment
ein sehr spannendes und mal sehen ob das
funktioniert nur ich kann mich nicht
selber spielen das wäre an der grenze
der lächerlichkeit schlimmer ist die
neue figur der pinka also eine neue
figur also eine grauenvolle vorstellung
man kann ja doch also wenn man es doch
zum schluss ist noch mal ein bisschen
übertragen ansieht unserer zeit ist ja
ein gewissermaßen aus den fugen also
auch wenn man die ganzen finanzkrisen
und diese ängste die moment da sind
anschaut
wir haben sehr jetzt gesehen auch wie
dieser weg ordnend wirkt was für jacobs
pfade bräuchten wir
also ich würde nicht sagen wollen dass
der jakobsweg ein allheilmittel ist
das würde ich nicht behaupten wollen ich
will ihnen auch nicht zu sehr
idealisieren
aber ich denke schon dass es unserer
modernen gesellschaft an form und auch
an inhalt fehlt die ausrichtung
es gibt keine aus richtung wohin gehen
wir
und ich denke es kann nur eine
ausrichtung geben die sich am menschen
orientiert ich will gar nicht sagen an
gott aber die sich am menschen und
seinen wahren bedürfnissen orientiert
und und das halte ich für eine ganz ganz
entsetzliche entwicklung des menschen am
ende gegen ihre eigenen bedürfnisse
handeln das ist so wenig verständlich es
ist ja ganz es ist ja nachvollziehbar
dass wenn es so banal aber wenn ich
meinem nächsten schade dann füge ich mir
einen viel größeren schaden zu es gibt
eine dame die hat dass man einem
beispiel gezeigt wenn sie hier jetzt ein
stück papier drüber tun und dann würde
das als unabhängige wesen oder menschen
sehen und nun versucht der mittelfinger
hat diesen finger zu bekämpfen und es
gelingt ihm und dann ist der weg jetzt
also am ende schade ich dem ganzen wenn
ich nur einem einzigen menschen schaden
zufügen ich finde das so offensichtlich
und das finde ich erstaunlich dass der
mensch dagegen seine eigenen bedürfnisse
handelt und glaubt dass das wohl am ende
gut sei und welche formen würden dann
dagegen helfe also haben wir gesagt ist
von formen
ich glaube dass viele menschen ihre
menschen ihre eigenen bedürfnisse nicht
kennen dass das ein bedürfnis nach macht
ein bedürfnis nach messbaren erfolg dass
all das das unten wonach unsere
gesellschaft ja ausgerichtet ist ich
meine es ist ganz simpel sich zu fragen
macht das bin ich glücklicher
dadurch dass ich jetzt drei millionen
bücher verkauft habe wäre es nicht wenn
es 10.000 gewesen wären wäre ich dass es
darum geht es nicht
und am ende wird man sich immer sagen
müssen nein es macht nicht glücklich es
geht um andere dinge aber es ist wie
gesagt auch das ist wiederum banal aber
wenn der mensch sich auf seine
wirklichen bedürfnisse wieder
konzentriert könnte das sicher nicht
mehr sicher nicht schlafen afrika in
vielen dank für dieses nachdenkliche
gespräch danke ihm
[Musik]
hape kerkeling im gespräch mit brigitte
rotach selbstverständlich ist auch
[Musik]